Wir bringen Kopfhörer raus, die schützen.
Ähm, wir sind hier immer
Öff-Jong, öff-Jong, sehr du.
Ist ne gute Idee, man muss natürlich nur irgendwie das Cringe-Zentrum dann f***en.
Einen wunderschönen guten Tag. Finden!
Korrektur, Intro-Korrektur, sorry, dass wir es leider in jeder einzelnen Folge machen müssen, aber finden, herzlich willkommen, schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid und vielen, vielen Dank an Samuel für dieses fantastische Intro. Danke, Samu. Samu, dass uns hier mal so. Tack Samu. Wie bitte? Vielen Dank Samu. Okay, alles klar. Ja, wir wissen nicht genau, wie man das ausspricht, aber wir freuen uns, dass er mit dabei ist und Stefan Tietze ebenso, Stefan Maria Kondelisa Tietze sitzt mir gegenüber.
Und Al Will auch vor mir am Start. Hallo, herzlich willkommen. Ja, es sind diese Momente, wo man denkt, ich habe mich versprochen, ich wusste nicht, ich kam nicht auf diesen Namen von diesem Helm. Und man denkt sich während der Aufnahme schon, ja, sollte man einfach mal parat haben oder googeln. Aber es wird sich schon versenden. Bei uns nicht. Bei uns machen dann Hörerinnen und Hörer Intros daraus. Die nehmen unsere schwächsten Punkte, die schwächsten Momente, so wie die Momente in Filmen, wo jemand sich verhaspelt und sagt, to be or not, to be, äh. Machen wir mit der nächsten Szene weiter und dann fokussieren die sich nur auf diese einen Momente. Ja, oder wie Kinder oder so junge Teenager, die genau deine Schwäche, wie so ein Haifisch herausfinden und das angreifen. Und auch direkt aussprechen einfach. Genau. Du bist dick. Oh mein Gott. Äh, ja. Also das ist sehr ernst. Naja, der Helm heißt Höfting. Höfting. 3.0. Aber die Firma ist jetzt glaube ich pleite. Oh, ist sie gestürzt? Was ist passiert? Ich glaube, da gibt es irgendwie so ein Problem, gab es ein bürokratisches Problem in Schweden, auf jeden Fall. Also das sind die Helme, die eigentlich keine Helme sind, sondern Airbag-Helme sind, wo ich ja die Theorie geäussert habe, dass die schlicht nicht funktionieren und es einfach nur Scharade ist und das irgendwann mal aufgefallen ist und die ganze Firma in sich eingestürzt ist. Doch, vor allem ein Kumpel von mir hat auch so einen Helm und der ist neulich mal, hat der ausgelöst und es sind dann immer, also dann muss man sich neu kaufen. Also, aber muss sich auch ein, ach so, muss sich auch ein, naja, war auch meine Reaktion, aber man muss sich auch ein Helm neu kaufen, wenn du fällst. Kann man dann damit nicht nochmal nach Hause fahren? Mit den Dingen um sich herum? Ja. Das weiß ich nicht genau. Also ich weiß auch nicht, wie das im Auto ist, ich habe einmal, und ich glaube, das war wahrscheinlich der demütigste Moment im Leben dieses Menschen, standen wir früher alle am Schulbusbahnhof, Bushaltestelle, ein Wort, das ich gleich seit 15 Jahren nicht mehr gesagt habe, Bushaltestelle, ein bisschen eingerostet. Und ein grosses Teil meines Lebens habe ich am Busbahnhof verbracht und stand da rum.
Und dann schaut man ja immer auf die Autos, die da aneinander vorbeifahren.
Und irgendwann blieb mein Auto stehen und das auto dahinter fuhr einfach rein ungebremst und dann ging der airbag auf ja und dann stand er mit seinem offenen airbag direkt vor irgendwie 20 achtklässlern die einfach angeguckt haben mit so einem du bist fett mit so einem das ist das interessanteste, was ich in meinem kurzen Leben je gesehen habe. Und ich weiß nicht mehr, was dann passiert ist, aber was ist denn, wenn du da mit einem Airbag stehst, faltet man den wieder zusammen oder fährt man dann, lässt man das Auto da stehen oder gibt es eine Möglichkeit, wie geht es weiter danach? so ein Spannbettlaken, wo auch niemand genau weiss, wie man das faltet und wo man noch, man hat, das ist so Spannbettlaken, wo auch niemand genau weiß, wie man das faltet und wo man noch, man hat, das ist so spannend beim Spannbettlaken, man hat die Hoffnung, man kriegt es hin, jedes Mal aufs Neue, dann legt man das Erste aufeinander, man halbiert es einmal quasi, denkt sich, besser als erwartet, okay, here we go, here we go, dann macht man es nochmal, dann passt aber schon alles nicht, weil es so verzogen ist und bla bla bla und dann irgendwann, wie es alle machen bei Spannbettlaken, dann einfach nur noch so, ja, okay, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tsch, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss, tschüss schon alles nicht, weil das so verzogen ist und bla bla bla. Und dann irgendwann, wie es alle machen bei Spannendlaken, dann einfach nur noch so, ja, okay, schweig, schweig, schweig, schweig, schweig, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, das war's. Und so stelle ich mir auch die Arbeit vor von Ingenieuren, Ingenieurinnen, die dann anfangen müssen, Airbags wieder einzuführen. Du meinst, die versuchen es auch erst zusammenzufalten und merken sie an, a, a, a, a, a, a, die klassische Herangehensweise eines Sicherheitsingenieurs, die sagt, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, a, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,angen, okay, aber ich habe noch die ganze Woche vor mir, also es bleibt noch ein bisschen liegen. Mittwoch, ja Mittwoch ist wirklich Mitte der Woche, da kann man immer entspannen, weil Donnerstag ist schon der kleine Freitag, ist schon fast Freitag, geht man abends auch mal mit Leuten das, Freitag macht man gar nichts mehr. Und vielleicht war sogar noch ein Brückentag in dieser Woche oder Ferien, das heißt, und alle arbeiten ja so, das ist ja das Mainset. Die hangeln sich durch. Alle hangeln sich so durch. Auch fucking Sicherheitsexperten? Ja, das ist richtig. Da muss man denken. Denkt daran, wenn ihr gerade mit 680 kmh in einem Zug sitzt, dann müsst ihr daran denken, niemand will arbeiten. Niemand will den Job machen. Der Typ, der die Bremse designt hat, der will früh nach Hause. Also deswegen ist es für mich ein Wunder, warum nicht viel mehr Unglücke passieren. Es ist wirklich ein Wunder, aber Bettlaken ist auch so ein Ding, wo im Laufe des Lebens die Schwierigkeitsgrad erhöht wird, habe ich das Gefühl. Du fängst ja an als Kind mit so einem Einzelbett, mit so einer einzelnen Matratze, wo das Bettlaken absolut simpel ist, kurze Seite, lange Seite, ganz einfach aufgebaut. 80 mal zwei Meter wahrscheinlich, 90 mal zwei Meter, 90 wahrscheinlich. Überhaupt kein Problem. Und irgendwann kommt man dann an den Punkt des Lebens und sagt, nee, ich will mehr Platz. Schlaf nimmt einen wichtigeren Teil meines Lebens ein, das Bett im Allgemeinen ist ein wichtigeres Möbelstück, anstatt irgendwie die Tarzan-chaukel oder irgendwie die Bowlingbahn in meinem Kinderzimmer. Und dann hat man irgendwann so ein Bett, was so 1,70 mal 1,90 ist, wo man wirklich hauchfeine Unterschiede zwischen den Seiten macht. Wo ich sage, mach ein Quadrat draus, mach ein Quadrat draus, aber nein, die Bettindustrie hält immer noch an diesem gedrückten Quadrat, an diesem kleinen Rechteck fest und dann bist du natürlich schon, sind es jetzt 1,70 oder 1,90 was ich in der Hand habe und mir ist es schon so oft passiert, dass ich es dann wirklich falsch gemacht habe, kurze Seite auf lange, lange Seite auf kurz. Aber es ist nicht klar. Es ist der Fehler, es ist nicht klar. Aber es ist so eine unangenehme Spannung auf dem Bett.
Spannung, deswegen Spannung beklagen.
Ja genau, aber das Bett merkt, da ist was falsch. Das ist so, wenn du den linken Schuh rechts anziehst oder so. Es ist so, es geht, du kommst durch den Tag, aber es ist so ein unangenehmer Vibe. Voll, ich finde auch, und es geht ja. Das ist das Problem. Meine 1,80er Seite passt ja auch auf die 2-Meter-Seite. Dann ist die 2-Meter-Seite ein bisschen übertrieben für die 1,80 Seite, aber es geht schon klar, es geht schon klar, das Spannbeklagen schreit nicht, ich passe nicht auf. Ja, aber auf der anderen Seite, du willst nicht die 1,80 Seite sein, die über Monate, sind wir ehrlich, auf zwei Metern gespannt ist und so, das hört bestimmt bald auf, das hört bestimmt bald auf, Monate. Wohingegen die zwei Meter auf der 1,80 Seite, so soll ich so ... Ich weiss überhaupt nicht, wo dein Problem ist gerade. Ich hab die Zeit meines Lebens. Die zwei Meter Seite ist eh die gechillte, weil die weiss, ihr kann nichts passieren. Entweder hat sie mehr Platz oder ist es genau richtig. Die zwei Meter Seite, das ist eigentlich auch eine gute Sitcom, oder? Die zwei Meter und die 1,80 Seite, einer ist super entspannt, ist so ein bisschen das Charlie-Chin-Modell. Mein Gott, du hast mich direkt durchschaut. Es ist so ein bisschen das Two-and-Half-Man. Und das Half-Man ist dann die Z-Achse, ist dann, wie es nach oben geht, die 30 cm Z-Achse. Unsere Pitches werden immer mathematischer. Also okay, also Sie kennen alle das Grundprinzip. Wir haben eine super entspannte X-Achse mit einem etwas neurotischen Y-Achsen-Charakter. Und jetzt kommt da aber auch noch eine kleine, süße Z-Achse rein, die das Ganze so ein bisschen aufwirbelt. Wir sind die deutschen Serien-Pitcher, die so mit ... Hier haben wir ein Fünf-Säulen-Modell der verschiedenen Emotionen, die in Serien vorkommen. Wir haben hier die X-Achse und die Y-Achse. Y steht in dem Fall für die Zeit, wo wir uns übernimmt. Wir haben eine Umfrage gemacht und haben festgestellt, Menschen mögen Humor. Also hat unsere Sendung auch Humor. Richtig, genau. Auf der X-Achse sehen wir den Ausschlag des Humors. Wir haben gedacht, wie viele Gags kriegen wir in eine halbe Stunde gepackt. Gagdichte muss hoch. Hier sehen wir, mit welcher Form wir das hinbekommen haben. Das E steht in diesem Fall für Emotionen, das T steht für Tragödie und das T für die Zeit. Wir von Build Your Series Org sind ...
Punkt D.
D.
Ja, D-E.
Naja, ich da ... Ja, wir bauen eure Serie dafür, dass ihr mehr Emotionen habt.
Ja.
Das ist so, weil genau so, das ist nämlich das Lustigste der Welt im Phantasialand. Ich habe das glaube ich schon mal erzählt, ich bin mir nicht sicher, unterbricht mich, wenn ich das schon mal erzählt habe. Aber im Phantasialand gibt es einen wahnsinnig tollen Soundtrack. Der ganze Park hat einen riesen Soundtrack, alles grossartig, die coolen Bahnen haben auch die besten Soundtracks. Und da habe ich mal geguckt, wer den gemacht hat. Und es ist wirklich, es ist eine deutsche Gruppe aus Musikern slash Software Engineers und die heissen Imascore. Yes. Und da haben die so ein Video, wie sie sich vorstellen und alle, es sind nicht die Musikerkünstler, die man sich vorstellt, sondern es sind so, die haben Polo-Shirts und oben steht immer Imascore, also alle haben diese Uniform an und reden von sehr mathematisch von ihrem Score, den sie geschrieben haben, ähnlich wie das. Und es fehlt wirklich so, wir haben fünf Säulenmodell aufgestellt und es wirkt so sehr mathematisch. Säule eins Reggae, wir haben die Reggae-Formel geknackt. Und die geht so mathematisch dran, so nach dem Motto, wir haben 15 Leute an unseren Gehirnstrommesser angeschlossen und geschaut, bei welchen Emotionen wollen sie welche Töne haben. Das haben wir in unserem Programm übertragen und hier haben wir folgenden Score rausbekommen und es ist eine so wunderschöne Disney-Musik, aber ich finde das sehr lustig, weil sie so sehr, auch mit dem Polo-Hamden und so einem IT-Gedanken da dran gehen. Ich fände das richtig stressig, wenn ich so ein Tester wäre. Ich denke immer so, diese Tester, auf denen ruht ja unglaublich viel Verantwortung. Kaum Anerkennung in der Gesellschaft, kaum Anerkennung für Essenstester, Süssigkeitentester, die irgendwas essen müssen und sagen Daumen hoch, Daumen runter. Und deswegen an der Stelle mal ein Shoutout an alle Testerinnen und Tester da draußen. Ihr testet gut, testet weiter, ihr seid für uns da. Oder ihr testet schlecht. We wouldn't know. Das ist das Problem. Wisst ihr es nicht. Wenn ihr sehr schlecht testet da draußen, haben wir vielleicht nur die Produkte, die wir kennen, weil wir sie kennen und essen, weil wir sie essen. Wir wissen nicht, was besser sein könnte. Es ist gefährlich. Ich bin jetzt, ich habe ja, muss ich sagen, wir sind ja, unter uns, kommen ja beide auch in ein gewisses Alter langsam. Die grauen Haare scheinen, die Knochen werden müder, der Rücken ächzt, all das. Und da gibt es natürlich eigentlich nur schlechte Nachrichten. Aber eine Nachricht freut mich dann doch, und zwar die Midlife-Crisis. Ich bin großer Freund der Midlife-Crisis und ich kann es kaum erwarten. Und ich habe schon immer so ein aufmerksames Auge in mein Leben hinein und denke mir, ist das schon, geht es schon los? Ist das schon was? Ist das schon was? Warum bewege ich mich mit 280 kmh auf einem motorrad ist das schon gerade was und deswegen immer bei neuen bei deinen phasen ich habe auch manchmal phasen aber so ein bisschen langschwelliger und ja leben genau hobbys interessen also ich denke mir schon ist es mit der crisis weil jetzt habe ich letztens angefangen mit scharfem essen Ich interessiere mich jetzt für scharfes Essen. Nichts vielleicht mit scharfem Essen. Nein, nicht mit scharfem Essen. Das ist auch lustig und ich erinnere an mein Projekt, wo ich das mit scharfem Essen.de, wo ich in den Alpen angeboten habe, das nur abends mit scharfen ist. Du hast festgestellt, dass Schafe wesentlich schlechtere Gesellschaftspartner sind, als du dachtest. Die sind unangenehm, die lästern, die sind rassistisch. Muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, das Abendessen... Das ist ein grosses Rassismusproblem mit den Schafen, das war furchtbar und ja, rückblickend, sorry an alle Beteiligten. Aber jetzt zu deinem scharfem Essen. Und ich bin extrem empfindlich für scharfes Essen. Das ist eine Midlife-Crisis. Ich weiß noch nicht, in welche Richtung es sich entwickelt.
Aber ich denke mir immer so,
wie geht's los? Ich mag ja den Anfang
von Filmen immer am liebsten. Deswegen, ich denke mir immer so,
das ist jetzt der Anfang, wie geht's weiter?
Irgendwann bin ich in so einem Chili-Contest,
Wettessen, irgendwann pflanze ich meine eigenen
Chilischoten an, entwickle die schärfste Chili der Welt,
dann gerät die irgendwie ins Grundwasser,
dann ist plötzlich alles wasserscharf,
nur noch die können überleben, die ein Toleranzlevel haben.
Und dann aus, weil du machst Anfänge von Filmen.
Genau, und dann geht die nächste Geschichte los.
Und da habe ich jetzt tatsächlich, durch Zufall habe ich es entdeckt, dass ich jetzt scharfes Essen esse, weil ich kam irgendwie am Bahnhof an, super spät, wollte mir noch was holen.
Beim Edeka im Hamburger Hauptbahnhof, können wir auch nochmal drüber reden, das ist ein besonderer edeka bitte lass uns dann eine folge für resen unbedingt unbedingt
nächste folge okay nächste folge nur in diesen edeka und dann habe ich noch ganz spät kaufe mir
so ein paar nudelpackungen noch ein wegballisto ne eben nicht ich habe mal zu was exotischerem
gegriffen aber dachte mir passt schon kommt zu hause an machen wir diese nudeln und sie sind
unessbar scharf ich hungrig scharfes denke mir, oh jetzt hat mir die Natur ein Bein gestellt einfach. Ich zwänge mir das Zeug runter, ab einem gewissen Punkt habe ich versucht, die Nudeln zu waschen, die Soße abzuwaschen, weil es unessbar scharf war, also wirklich unerträglich scharf. Und da dachte ich mir, ich muss härter werden, ich muss die Toleranz aufbauen und habe auch gemerkt, dass diese Nudeln, die ich da gekauft habe, willkürlich waren Huhn drauf, absolut die schärfsten sind, die es irgendwie gibt. Aber kann man das denn, kann man denn eine Scheife Toleranz aufbauen? Ich glaube schon. Das erste, was ich gemacht habe, ich habe mit hochrotem Kopf und tränen in den Augen den Wikipedia-Artikel gelesen von Schärfe, weil ich wissen wollte, was geschieht hier, was passiert mit mir, was ist los, warum
schmerzt mein Körper so?
Wenn der Artikel sagt, das ist nur eine, dein Körper simuliert
ein Schmerzgefühl, was eigentlich gar nicht
da ist, hilft es nicht,
weil das Gehirn, weil auch
keine Ahnung, Vorstellungen oder Ängste
sind ja oft nicht rational, trotzdem hat man sie,
das Gehirn ist einfach sehr stark. Du schaust
unterm Bett nach und siehst, da ist kein Monster,
aber du hast trotzdem noch Angst, dass ein Monster unterm Bett ist. Und diese Angst ist wiederum sehr real. Richtig, sehr, sehr real. Ja. Sehr real. Und äh... Wie real? Also weil es ist kein Monster. Ich schreie mich in den Schlaf, jede Nacht. Ja, das höre ich bis nach Köln. Ich habe aber auch ein Hochbett, also da können viele, viele Monster darunter sein. Und riesige
auch. Sehr grosse. Und
Wikipedia-Artikel habe ich auch gelesen,
und das fand ich ganz spannend, weil du denkst, ja, warum machen wir
Menschen das, warum sind wir so dumm und
essen Pflanzen? Und im Wikipedia-Artikel stand,
die Pflanzen haben Schärfe
entwickelt, damit sie nicht
von Säugetieren, sondern
von Vögeln gegessen werden.
Weil Vögel haben
in ihrem Schnabel nichts.
Die schmecken anscheinend nichts,
die fühlen nichts, die kriegen das
nichts mit. Also Dinosaurier konnten nicht schmecken.
Ist das, was du mir jetzt sagen willst?
Dinosaurier waren völlig taub,
völlig taub, die haben ihr Essen nicht gekocht.
Echt? Völlig egal. Ich weiß nicht, welche Richtung macht sie weder cooler noch uncooler, für mich bleibt es neutral. Ja, aber ich glaube so ein Schnabel, ich weiß nicht, ob da Geschmacksnerven drin sind oder ob das einfach alles völlig egal ist, aber anscheinend war es evolutionär sinnvoller, von Vögeln gegessen zu werden, weil die die dann weiter wegtreiben, die können schneller fliegen und so weiter und so weiter. Weil die beherrschen den Himmel, dann hat die Pflanze gesagt, dann beherrschen
wir auch den Himmel. Richtig. Aber ich finde
das so eine geile, evolutionäre Überlegung,
wenn man sagt, wir möchten
bitte von Vögeln gefressen
werden, wo ich mir denke,
wenn du da reinkommst,
Chef, ganz kurz, ich habe jetzt
gelesen, Programm für 2024,
dass wir von Vögeln
gefressen werden wollen. Genau richtig, ja, das ist die Idee jetzt. Ich dachte, vielleicht können wir einfach gar nicht gefressen werden. Weil, ich meine, die fressen uns auf und es tut weh und wir sind dann im Magen drin und so und weil, ich finde die Idee gut mit dem Schärfe, dass uns Säugetiere nicht essen, aber wäre es vielleicht nicht besser, wenn uns einfach gar nichts isst? Hä, Wilhelm, warum sagen Sie das jetzt jetzt? Wir haben das so gleich am Schirm. Sie haben das mit so einem viel Esprit und so einem Schillern in den Augen vorgetragen. Vor sechs Wochen ging die Mail rum. Wir wollen weniger gefressen werden. Habt Ideen. Da habe ich extra diesen Kasten aufgebaut. Ja. Sie wussten von dem Kasten. Ich wusste von dem Kasten. Das ist ein süßer Kasten mit den Stickern von meiner Tochter. Sie haben sich offensichtlich viel Mühe mit dem Kasten gegeben. Der Kasten ist süss. Ich fand das eine süße Idee. Er fällt ein bisschen aus dem sehr strengen Corporate Design unserer Firma raus, weil er ist so ein bisschen unsymmetrisch aus Holz gezimmert. Hat Ihre Tochter den ganzen Kasten gebaut? Nein, der Kasten ist von mir. Die Sticker sind von der Tochter. Das tut mir leid, ich sage ein bisschen... Aber jetzt genug vom Kasten! Ein kindliches... Sie haben eine Idee, dass wir nicht mehr gefressen werden? Ich dachte, es ist okay, wenn wir zumindest nur noch von Vögeln gefressen werden, weil die beherrschen die Lüfte. Und so beherrschen auch wir die Lüfte. Ja, aber wäre es nicht besser, einfach überhaupt nicht. Nie, nie, also ich will jetzt nicht ständig über unsere Konkurrenzfirma, den Kaktus, sprechen. Aber der hat einfach Stachel. Unsere grossen Rivalen. Bitte, beruhigen Sie sich, setzen Sie sich. Das sind keine Pflanzen wie wir, augenscheinlich. Ja, aber schauen Sie, der hat einfach Stacheln gegen alles. Stacheln gegen Vögel, Stacheln gegen Säugetiere, gegen Würmer. Wir können nicht auch Stacheln machen. Nee, das meine ich nicht, das meine ich gar nicht. Ich meine nur, dass der halt gesagt, lasst mich bitte alle komplett in Ruhe, wenn es geht. Wohingegen wir aktiv mit unserer roten Farbe und unserem himmlischen Geschmack aktiv Vögel anziehen. Warum? Naja, weil die beherrschen die Lüfte. Ich wollte es nur mal sagen, weil wir uns langsam Sorgen machen, weil Paul wurde jetzt gefressen. Verdammt. Und es war kein schöner Anblick, die Vögel haben ihn völlig. Was waren Vögel? Ja, aber es war trotzdem extrem schmerzhaft. Aber jetzt frage ich dich weiter, Hevel Helmy. Wir sind beim Nachnamen und du. Wir sind beim Nachnamen, ja, kein Problem. Hevel Helmy, jetzt frage ich dich nochmal eine andere Sache. Dieser Vogel, der ihn gefressen hat, Paul in allen Ehren, rest in peace, war ein guter Mitarbeiter. Tolle Ideen, hat viele Ideen reingeworfen in den Kasten. Aber gut, ist keine Kritik. Moment, der Kasten sollte anonym sein. Sie haben gesagt, der Kasten ist anonym. Ja. Woher wissen Sie, dass Paul besonders viele Zettel in den Kasten geworfen hat? Kennst du diese Kameras, wenn man Vögelhäuschen, Vögel beobachtenachten kann? Ich dachte, ich habe die einfach, ich habe eine Kamera in den Kasten gemacht, weil ich schon sehen wollte, wer die besten Ideen hat. Sie haben keines reingeworfen. Sie hätten die Frage schon stellen können bei der Frage, haben sie was reingeworfen, sie haben nichts reingeworfen. Aber gut, der Kasten war nicht so ganz anonym. Sorry, dafür möchte ich mich in aller Form entschuldigen. Aber, Frage, was passiert mit Paul, wenn er über den nächsten Feldern, nicht in diesem Land, sondern im nächsten Land, übernächsten Land, der Kot der Vögel landet in den Feldern? Paul wird bald überall sein. Sie meinen die Koten während dem Fliegen? Die Koten während des Fliegens. Wirklich? Ja, Vögelkoten während des Fliegens. Wie meinen Sie, die setzen sich hin? Ja, aber auch das tun sie ja in anderen Ländern vielleicht.
Paul wird bald überall sein. Pauls Nachkommen.
Wo sind sie? Wo sind sie in 20 Jahren?
Naja, ich wurde zumindest nicht zerfetzt von Vögelschnäbeln.
Das ist nur ein kleiner Step.
Vielleicht haben Sie recht. Vielleicht sollten wir an das große Ganze...
Niemand weiß, wie Pflanzen funktionieren. Existieren wir, denken wir gerade, wissen wir, dass wir leben, haben wir Bewusstsein? Vermutlich nicht. Paul ist bald überall. Und jetzt gehen Sie da raus und schmeißen Ideen in den Kasten. Okay, ja, alles klar. Danke, Chef.
Ja, ich würde gerne bei Ihnen arbeiten. Ich habe bislang bei den Chilis gearbeitet. Haben Sie noch einen Platz frei bei den Kakteen? Mir gefällt irgendwie Ihr Arbeitsklima so ein bisschen besser. Wir sind perfekt, wie wir sind. Wir brauchen niemanden, der bei uns arbeitet. Okay, dann gehe ich wieder. Passen Sie auf, passen Sie auf. Au, au, au! Und das sind die Pflanzen, das sind neue Pixar, das war, das war ein kleiner Einblick in den Trailer vom neuen Pixar-Film. Ein Einblick in den Trailer, ein kurzer Ausschnitt, ein kurzer Ausschnitt aus dem Trailer. Du lachst laut, du lachst gerade sehr laut, sehr, sehr laut, aber das ist tatsächlich, was Teasertrailer sind, oder nicht?
Ja, ein Trailer vom Trailer.
Ja, ein Trailer in einem Trailer. Gewisserweise, ja.
Ein Trailer in einem Trailer.
Das stimmt schon. Wir gucken mal kurz in den Trailer rein.
Wir gucken mal kurz in den Trailer.
Der in den Film reinguckt.
Der wiederum in die Reihe reinguckt.
Das ist wie wenn du mit einem Fernglas in ein Fernglas schaust.
Oder ein Trailer mit einem Fernglas schaust.
Ja, oder wenn du ein Fernglas falsch rumhältst und damit in ein Fernglas schaust, schaust du dann wieder ganz normal? Ist es die dümmste, die aufwendigste Brille der Welt? Und schaust du dann, brauchst du dann noch eine Brille? Vermutlich ja, das habe ich schon mal auf mich gefragt. Ach so, Ferngläser mit Stärke. Ja, Spiegel sagen, ja, Spiegel sind wie jetzt, Spiegel sind komisch, habe ich bis heute nicht verstanden.
Weil Spiegel keine Stärke brauchen, meinst du? Nein, weil ich habe mir mal gedacht, wenn ich kurzsichtig bin, aber der Spiegel ist direkt vor mir, sehe ich dann, kann ich dann nach hinten gucken, ohne eine Brille zu brauchen, weil, was ich, ich bin kurzsichtig, aber ich sehe ja sehr, ich sehe ja, der Spiegel ist ja direkt vor mir. Ich verstehe schon, ja. Aber der Spiegel spiegelt ja nur. Und das kann ich ja nicht scharf stellen. Aber ich verstehe nicht warum, weil ich gucke ja nur, wenn man sagt, die ersten 50 cm sind gestochen scharf. Und dann beginnt die Kurzsichtigkeit. So, als wäre es ein Bildschirm, wo du den Bildschirm siehst. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Ist schwierig. Du weigerst dich seit Jahren eine Brille zu kaufen, weil du an deine Spieltheorie glaubst. Ich laufe in vollidiot durch die Stadt, ja. Du siehst ja auch alles spiegelverkehrt und hinter dir dann nur. Ne, dafür habe ich mir so eine elaborierte Brille geprobt. Ah, okay. Mit so ganz vielen Spiegeln. Ich kann um alle Ecken gucken. Die Doppelspiegeln verstehe. Ja, das ist schwierig. Okay, und wie weit bist du gekommen? Also die Evolution hat dann gesagt, wir wollen von, aber es ist doch wirklich so, die wollen von Vögeln gefressen werden, weil Vögel treiben die Samen in die Welt. Genau. Die Samen in die Welt. Ja, und der Plan ist aber nicht hundertprozentig aufgegangen, weil ich bin jetzt ein Säugetier und ich bewege mich nicht weit weg von dem Ort, an dem ich die scharfen Sachen gegessen habe, sondern ich bleibe da, wo ich bin. Du bist mein Mann in Hamburg. Die werden überhaupt nicht weiter verbreitet. Und wir essen sie jetzt wegen ihrer Abwehrmechanismen, explizit gegen Säugetiere, sagen wir, oh, wir mögen den Schmerz, wir lieben die Energie, wir wollen was fühlen, das Schmerzgefühl. Und ja, da bin ich jetzt gerade dabei, mich zu desensibilisieren, weil ich möchte was fühlen, aber nicht so viel. Und jetzt, diese Nud die bandok oder bank bank oder irgendwie sowas die auf so einem hun aufbauen und da habe ich die letztens in einem kiosk gekauft wo selbst der kioskverkäufer meinte die sind aber wirklich sehr scharf kennt der kioskbesitzer wie leute die eine bücherei arbeiten alle bücher ja anscheinend schon. Anscheinend hat er alles selber mal durchprobiert und
hat aber anscheinend auch schon viele Leute
versorgt, die irgendwie zehn Minuten
später röchelnd zu ihm kamen
und meinten, ich sterbe jetzt wieder
rein.
Naja, ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Wo läuft
man denn hin? Kann man in eine Apotheke
laufen und sagen,
Milchhändler?
Was ist los? Wie alle Apotheker reagieren. Was ist los? Was ist los? Drück dich mal aus, Kollege. Apotheker und Apothekerinnen sind so verständnisvolle, tolle Menschen. Ja, ich hätte gern die Kondome für die extra kleinen Penisse, bitte. Klar, natürlich. Für den winzigen und die Schnellkondome. Die Schnellkondome für die extra winzigen. Damit sie nicht so schnell ejakulieren? Genau, genau. Ah, okay, alles klar, natürlich. Für die ganz und dann für den Arsch ausschlag, die Tabletten bitte. Alles klar, haben Sie Erfahrung mit denen? Sie wissen, wie Sie sie einnehmen. Ja, genau, also für den verpickelten Riesenarsch hätte ich die gerne. Alles klar. Das sind einmal die Bialurali. Alles klar. Haben Sie damit erfahren, hat der Arzt gesagt, wie Sie die einnehmen? Ich nehme die seit vielen Jahren intensiv. Ich habe seit meiner Kindheit einen komplett angeschwollenen, durch Verwarzen, komplett mit Ausschlag übersäten, innen und außen, überall verwandten Arsch und dann noch die Tabletten für wenig Selbstbewusstsein, Minderwertigkeitsgefühle und einen sehr ausgeprägten Vaterkomplex. Haben Sie noch diese Magazine da, diese ganz schmutzigen Stiefschwestermagazine? Ja, dann nehme ich davon auch noch einige. Alles klar, bitteschön. Und wir legen noch ein Emoikal dazu. Dankeschön. Einen schönen Tag wünsche ich Ihnen. Wiedersehen. Sie geben einem das Gefühl, als wäre man der normalste Mensch in der Welt, obwohl man so weirde Sachen hat. Und dann geht man da hin und die sind so nett. Die sind super nett, ja. Ich hätte gerne so einen Hammer, mit dem man Menschen quälen kann. Aha, möchtest du den kleinen oder den grossen? Gern den grossen direkt. Okay, dann packen gehen den 50er Pack. Alles klar, ja, kein Problem, bitteschön. Genau, aber die es richtig wehtut. Alles in griffreichreich. Alles in griffreichreich. Alles in griffreichreich. Alles, die erste Schublade, alles ist die erste Schublade, als wäre es der ganz normalste Einkauf aller Zeiten. Ja, ganz normal, kein Problem. Ich finde die fantastisch, ich liebe die dafür. Ja, ich finde die auch großartig. Aber ich gehe super ungern in Apotheken, weil ich immer nicht weiss, was die von einem wissen wollen oder so, ob die einem alles immer verkaufen dürfen. Ich habe tatsächlich nie Apotheken zu tun, aber hatte letztens grosse Rückenschmerzen und wollte Aspirin kaufen. Du auch? Ja, ich hatte grosse Rückenschmerzen.
Im Ibu. Ich sag dir, ich bin ein Fan inzwischen von Ibu.
Ich weiss es eben nicht, ich kenne mich da nicht aus.
Ja, Aspirin verdünnt dein Blut. Das willst du ja nicht, du willst ja kein dünnes Blut. Du hast lächerlich dünnes Blut. Mir ist völlig egal, was diese Sachen machen. Für mich ist das eh alles Placebo. Ich nehme das und versuche, mich besser zu fühlen. Aber, nein, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das ist. Aber es ist eh, ich meine, ich hatte solche Schmerzen, wo ich denke, wenn mir jetzt nicht irgendwie die Nervenbahnen durchgeschnitten werden, ist eh alles egal. Was ist passiert? Ich habe auch ganz, ganz schlimme Rückenschmerzen gerade. Bin auch gerade auf Ibuprofen, hört man vielleicht. Du hast dann so dieses helle Schimmernde in deiner Stimme, in den Obertönen. Ja, ich hatte grosse Schmerzen, weil ich ein Vollidiot bin und mich nicht um meinen Körper kümmere. Kann man eigentlich relativ direkt zusammenfassen. Und dann vor allem hatte ich grosse Schmerzen, da war ich über die Feiertage weg und dann kam ich zurück und dann hatte ich nur noch so, sagen wir mal, 30 Prozent des unerträglichen Schmerzes und dachte mir, ach ja komm, jetzt fängst du an mit Training, jetzt machst du was Gutes und ich habe ja so eine Faszienrolle, einfach so eine steinharte Rolle, wo man sich so rumrollen kann, jetzt knetest du das mal durch und so, hab mich da draufgelegt und von 30% ging es wieder auf 100%. Ich habe mein Leiden um zwei Tage verlängert und dachte mir, du bist der größte Vollidiot der Welt. Und dann kam zum Rückenschmerz noch der schlimmste Schmerz, der ich bin selber Schuldschmerz, nicht die Evolution, weil ich dann auch gelesen habe, eigentlich sollen Menschen gar nicht unbedingt aufrechtlaufen und die Anatomie ist dafür gar nicht gedacht. Und dann kommt dann ein Mensch. Dann dachte ich mir an, dann dachte ich, ja gut, das ist nicht meine Schuld. Die dummen Affen, die meinten eines Tages, sie wollen aufrecht gehen. Ja und was wärst du für ein Vollidot, wenn das der Einzige wär, der nicht mehr aufrecht geht? Ja, das stimmt auch. Und dann kommen die Studien raus, der Mensch ist auch nicht mehr dafür gemacht, auf allen Vieren zu gehen. der Mensch ist so dazwischen. Der Schwanz ist jetzt weg, den kriegen wir nicht mehr zurück, selbst wenn wir jetzt Milliarden Jahre wieder anfangen auf allen Vieren zu laufen, vielleicht kommt er wieder, vielleicht sagt er dann, ah, sieh an, sieh an, sieh an, wer dann wieder zurückkommt. Wenn man auf vier Beinen geht, willst du? Alles, was vier Beine hat, hat einen Schwanz. Also gehe ich davon aus, dass ...
Boah, das war jetzt ein Hot Take. Ich rede schnell weiter, damit niemand nachdenken kann. Hot Take. Und deswegen denke ich mir, dass man, wenn man vier Beine hat, dann auch einen Schwanz braucht. Haben alle Tiere, die auf vier Beinen laufen, einen Schwanz können die abwerfen? Ja, das stimmt, aber trotzdem haben sie ihn. Ich glaube nein, nicht alle Tiere, die auf vier Beinen laufen, haben einen Schwanz, während viele vier Beine... Seitdem du diesen Computer geschenkt bekommen hast, bei dieser Tombola, wo du losgezogen hast, bist du echt unerträglich geworden. Es ist wie so ein Film aus den 80ern, der die Zukunft zeigt, ist es jetzt wirklich möglich. Ja. Computer, haben alle Tiere, die auf vier Beinen laufen, auch einen Schwanz? Computer, habe ich recht? Computer. Ah ja, Computer sagt ja. Und dann sagt Hell 9000 sagt dann zu uns, ja, ich habe ihre Konversation belauscht. Nicht alle Tiere, die auf vier Beinen laufen, haben einen Schwanz. Während viele vier Beine, wie Hunde, Katzen, Pferde, Schwänze haben, gibt es Ausnahmen. Ein bekanntes Beispiel ist der menschliche Pavian, eine Primatenart, die auf vier Beinen läuft und nur einen kurzen, kaum sichtbaren Schwanz hat. Auch einige andere Primaten und bestimmte Rassen von Hunden können sehr kurze oder praktisch nicht vorhandene Schwänze haben. Darüber hinaus können manche Tiere durch genetische Variationen, Krankheiten oder Verletzungen ohne sichtbaren Schwanz gebucht. Nein, nein, nein, nein, du hast schon recht. Also kurze Schwänze zählen erstmal als Schwanz, so, da sind wir uns alle einig. Und der menschliche Pavian, ja sorry, wenn der schon menschlich im Namen hat, ist er kein Tier. Pavian. Teropithecus gelada, gelada, das ist irgendwie der Eisdiele, ehrlich gesagt. Ich finde, du hast schon recht, du hast schon recht. Gefällt mir eigentlich ganz gut. Ich habe auch ganz schlimme Rückenschmerzen die letzte Woche gehabt, bis heute, aus dem komplett gegenteiligen Grund. Du hast Rückenschmerzen, weil du dich nicht um deinen Körper kümmerst. Ich war im Sport, beim Sport habe ich mir den Rücken verletzt. Und das ist ganz, ganz schlimm. Wie geschah das? Das habe ich so, einmal im Jahr habe ich das tatsächlich, bei einer Übung, Kreuzheben, auch bescheuerte Übung, wo du dich nach vorne die jesus übung oder was wurde so ein großes kreuz hochheben genau wo du ein kreuz durch die menschengassen tragen muss und auf dem berg wie es noch mal sie nahe und ja ne ist kreuzheben ist ja diese übung wo man diese lange hantel hat vor sich mit diesen Riesengewichten, man stellt sich da vor, bebeult sich nach vorne. Riesengewichten, ja. Naja, mit diesen riesigen, tonnenschweren, also nur damit ihr euch das jetzt vorstellen könnt. Also da ist eine Stängel an der Hand und da sind riesige Gewichte an den Seiten, also enorme riesige Gewichte. Stellt euch viel vor und verdoppelt das.
Ich meine mit denen diese,
auch wenn es nur fünf Kilo wären,
was es nicht sind, weil es sehr viel Gewicht ist,
sind die so riesig gross,
so grossen Scheiben. Ja, dann beugt man sich runter und hebt es halt hoch. Ich hasse diese Übung
auch, habe auch Angst vor der Übung, ist glaube ich
auch ein Grund, warum die dann nicht funktioniert.
Aber das war die Übung, wo
noch vor einer Woche ein Trainer daneben stand, hasse ich ja, wenn die zu einem kommen und die Form bewerten. Aber er hat dann diesen Mund nach unten ziehen und Daumen hoch Blick gemacht. Dieses Ah ja, okay. Ja. Und hat gesagt, mach's richtig gut. Ich dachte mir, Dankeschön, Dankeschön. Können nicht alle Trainer zu mir kommen und sagen, ich mach's gut. Vielleicht war es auch gar kein Trainer, vielleicht war es auch einfach jemand, der Leuten ein gutes Gefühl geben wollte. Ja, ebenfalls lief gut. Oder Schlaganfall, man weiss es nicht. Kann auch sein. Und bei der Übung, die ach so toll, die ich ach so toll mache, dass man zu mir kommt und die Daumen hoch geht. Den ach so riesigen Gewichten. Den ach so tollen Gewichten und der ach so großen Langhantel. Ja, dann macht man den Rücken irgendwie zu und man kann nicht mehr gehen praktisch. Also ich kann, man wackelt nur noch so rum. Dann bin ich zum Arzt gegangen, hab vier Spritzen bekommen tatsächlich. Vier Spritzen rein. Du standest an einem Wartezimmer, oder was? Oder kannst du dich setzen? Ja, man kann sich so setzen, aber es ist nicht so angenehm. Nichts ist angenehm, weder sitzen noch liegen.
Und man, das ist so spannend bei diesem, weil ich weiss, was es ist, es ist entweder so eine Lendenwirbelsäulenblockade, was auch immer, Hexenschuss oder was immer die Diagnose war, Iliosakralgelenkblockade. So ein Gelenk, das blutiert, das macht zu, Nerven werden eingedutscht. so und dann das ist nicht so schlimm ist dass das heilt von alleine es verursacht keine
bleibenden schäden es ist nicht so schlimm ist dass das heilt von alleine es verursacht keine bleibenden schäden es ist nicht schlimm als als diagnose ja es tut nur so weh und der körper sagt das war es für uns wir können jetzt nicht mehr gehen und das ist so lustig obwohl man weiss dass man bald alles alles wieder gut ist weil ich habe schon zwei mal gehabt und nach einer woche ist eigentlich wieder alles gut, sagt mein Geist trotzdem, das war es für uns. Schmerz ist so dumm, einfach Schmerz ist wie so Spam, Schmerz der Spam des Körpers, wo du einfach weisst, mich interessiert das nicht, ich habe alle Informationen, aber du kriegst ständig Nachrichten und musst dir alle Hände schlöschen und es ist furchtbar, aber ich wünsche dir gute Besserung auf jeden Fall. Du stehst unter starken Medikamenten,
nehme ich an. Ja, im Ibu 400.
Aber wäre es nicht gut
in so Fitnessstudios, mit denen ich ja gar keine Erfahrung
habe, dass die, also weil die Gewichte
müssen ja nicht notwendigerweise so gross sein, wie sie
schwer sind. Wäre es nicht besser, die schweren
Gewichte klein zu machen und die leichten
Gewichte gross, so dass man wirklich
mal gucken kann, wem geht es wirklich nur um
Darstellung und wen gibt es wirklich um Training? Weil dann kannst du sagen, oh, ich fange mit den grossen Gewichten an, fühlt sich gut und dann aber die wirklich starken, die nehmen die kleinen. Puh, ist natürlich schwierig, weil man relativ schnell schnallt, dass es umgedreht in diesem Fitnessstudio ist. Ja, ich weiß es nicht. Meinst du? Naja, du willst ja den anderen Leuten, die mit dir trainieren, zeigen, wie stark du bist.
Genau, dann nimm stark du bist. Genau. Deswegen macht ja jeder, wenn du von der Maschine weggehst, nimmst du das Ding und machst es auf mehr Gewicht, als du eigentlich trainiert hast. Damit alle, die nach dir auch das Gewicht denken, sagen, oh krass, der sah so schwach und stimmlich aus und hat aber trotzdem 140 Kilo gehoben. Der hat 90 LBS gestemmt, warum auch immer das die Abkürzung für Pfund ist. Weil es die grössere Zahl ist. Pfund. Deswegen machen die auch Pfund und nicht Kilo, weil die Zahl grösser ist. Das ist alles nur Psychologie, das ist alles nur Scharade. Und deswegen sage ich auch, mach die Gewichte gross, mach sie riesengross, dann pumpen wir so gerne, dann ist hier mal was los, so macht die Gewichte gross, ja, da macht sie gross. Ich finde, du musst deine Botschaft immer mit einem schmissigen Song auch unterstützen, sonst funktioniert es nicht, die Leute packen das sonst nicht an. Ja, hat Sau weh getan. Es ist wirklich furchtbar, vor allem, ich habe ja dann zumindest eine Badewanne, wo ich mich reinlegen kann. Aber ich auch. Weil das Einzige, was dann hilft, ist wirklich warmes Wasser. Und ich dusche dann alle 15 Minuten und denke mir, ist das mein Leben? Weißt du, was ich gemacht habe? Ich habe mich in die Wanne gelegt und Latschenkiefer reingemacht. Yes! Ich habe den Floh in die Wanne gemacht. Olpifloh, Olpif! Herbertzin. Herbertzins Nein, Herberzin. Herberzins?
Ich habe Herberzin Latschenkiefer genommen.
Weil ein Kommentar.
Und ich empfehle dir explizit Alpiflor Latschenkiefer.
Pass auf.
Und du erzählst mir stolz, ich habe jetzt Latschenkiefer, aber dann nicht von Alpiflor.
Das Lustige ist.
Warum?
Es kam ein Kommentar unter der Folge von einem Hörer von uns, war, ah mega, ich nehme auch immer Latschenkieferbäder, ich mag die von Herbertzi noch ein bisschen lieber. Und diesem Menschen, den ich nicht kenne, habe ich mehr vertraut bei seiner Ausweisung seiner Latschenkieferbäder als dir. Nee, dann ist ja klar, dann ist ja die Ordnung jetzt.
Nee, ich habe das nicht gefunden, ich habe Albi Flon nicht gefunden, bin ich ehrlich.
Ich weiss nicht, gab es nicht in meinem DM, gab es nicht in meinem Rostmann.
Früher grüne Flasche, heute weisse Flasche.
Früher war alles besser, sagen die Leute, doch früher hatte Albi Flon eine grüne Flasche.
Als sie rot war in den 80ern, das war weird, hat sie niemand gekauft. Okay. Das ist ein Kindersong, sollte es eigentlich sein. Ja, ähm. Ich weiß nicht, so schmissig. Wie lernt man, wenn man Schärfetoleranz aufbauen kann, kann man doch bestimmt auch Freestyle-Skills aufbauen. Bestimmt, ich glaube, man kann Dinge lernen. Nee. Meinst du? Wir haben seit zehn Jahren versuchen wir das. Das stimmt, Salz, Pfeffer, Salz. Salz, Essen, Folge. Nichts reimt sich auf Salz. Schmalz, Malz, Schmalz, Malz, dann Knallz. Pfalz, Pfalz. Ja, das fällt dir alles jetzt im Nachhinein ein, aber nicht in dem Moment. Wir haben damals ja auch Freestyle gerappt, immer versucht und haben irgendwann diese Beats, die wir hatten, immer langsamer gemacht, weil wir dachten, naja, wenn wir einfach mehr Zeit haben. Kann man ja bei YouTube, man kann so eine Viertelgeschwindigkeit und das war dann irgendwie so und wir sassen da immer Mein Name ist Stefan, das Fund steht für Spaß, ich finke deine Mutter und wir geben ordentlich Gas, ordentlich Gas, Evgen, ich habe das Evgenleben. wie die rappenden Messdiener aber das interessante war, dadurch dass man so langsam war
ist man so ganz langsam Es ist Efre Leben. Wie mit dem Rappenden Messdiener.
Aber das Interessante war, dadurch, dass man so langsam war, ist man so ganz langsam und sicher auf eine Wand zugefahren. Du hattest dir Salz. Augen wurden grösser. Du wusstest ganz genau. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, mir fällt nichts auf Salz ein und du fährst gegen die Wand. Liebe dich, du bist mein Lieblingsmensch, wenn ich dich in den Arm schliessend bin. Man fährt langsam, aber ganz langsam gegen die Wand. Und genau in dem Moment, als wir es zum ersten Mal gemacht haben, kam Dendemann in den Raum, weisst du es noch? Ich erinnere mich gut, ja. Wir haben es zum ersten Mal gemacht, dachten, komm jetzt ist es ihr Scheiss egal, haben den Beat auf ganz langsam gestellt. Lächerlich, ein lächerlicher Anblick. Wir, zwei Menschen, bei denen nichts Hip-Hop sagt, überhaupt nichts. Wir sassen dann da so, wippend, mit gross aufgerissenen Augen, angstroten Köpfen, weil wir überlegen, Krampfer, und der Beat ist auf 12 BPM und dann kommt Dendemann rein und sieht das. Einer der besten Rapper Deutschlands. Dann denkst du, okay, Hip-Hop ist verloren. Hip-Hop ist verloren. Wenn das die nächste Generation ist, dann war es das. Punk ist tot, jetzt ist auch Hip-Hop tot. Der Tag, an dem Hip-Hop startet. Und dann hat er die Sendung verlassen. Was stirbt als... Welche Musikrichtung stirbt als nächstes? Was sagst du, wo, so würdest du sagen, Ska? Aber hat Ska wirklich jemals gelebt? Ska ist immer noch schon lange tot, wandelt in die tote Musikrichtung. Ne, gute Frage, ich sage Country, es gab ja diesen Country-Hype
mit diesen wirklich grossen Mainstream-Songs
auch, die über die klassischen
USA-Grenzen hinausgeschwappt sind.
Glaubst du, Country hält sich?
Ja, ich glaube, Country hält sich, ehrlich gesagt.
Das wird sich immer noch halten, die Menge,
die es hören, ist auch relativ gross und so.
Wo wir gerade bei Musik sind,
es gibt mittlerweile, du hast ja die
App Music League vorgeschlagen, wo man sich für seinen tollen Musikgeschmack feiern kann und mit anderen Freunden gewisse Songs finden muss für gewisse Songherausforderungen, bester Song für die Beerdigung, bester Song für ein erstes Date, solche Geschichten. Und da gibt es mittlerweile eine Podcast-UFO-Gruppe. Ah, cool. Music League Podcast-UFO-Gruppe ist im Reddit zu finden.
Könnt ihr joinen und könnt euch auf wichtige Kämpfe und Debatten einstellen. Ich habe auch teilgenommen. Das Ganze ist ja anonym und ich werde zu jeder einzelnen Herausforderung Lebt Deinen Traum den Digimon-Intero-Song posten. Okay. Und dann schauen wir mal, wie viele Punkte ich kriege. Wenn du es einmal machst und es wird gevotet, dann sieht man ja, wie viele Punkte du hast. Und wer den Song eingereicht hat. Dann werden wir das eben sehen. Dann bin ich auch bereit, den Aktensturz zu vollführen. Und dann lege ich alles offen. Dann lege ich alles offen. Super, ja, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie das folgt. Dann kriegt ihr meine Adresse, dann kriegt ihr meine Kontonummer, Sozialversicherungsnummer, meinen aktuellen Kontostand, dann kriegt ihr alles, wirklich alles, Schlüssel zu meiner Wohnung, denn dann lege ich komplett alles offen. Dann habe ich keine Geheimnisse mehr vor euch. Okay. Ich wollte noch kurz nachtragen, der Helm, bei dem kamen wir, da haben wir kurz die Abbildung genommen. Ja, da sind wir kurz gestürzt. Weil das Unternehmen verwies stolz auf Studien, wonach ihr Produkt einen bis zu achtmal höheren Schutz vor einer Gehirnerschütterung, vielleicht zu herkömmlichen Radhelm biete. Dafür registrierte der Höfding 200 Mal in der Sekunde die Bewegung des oder der Radfahren und löste bei einer Bewegung, die ein Unfall bzw. Sturz signalisiere, halt aus. Allerdings gab es mit dem aktuellen Modrei offensichtlich Softwarebleme. Im Jahr 2022 gab es Berichte, wonach sich der Akku des Höfting bei einigen Kunden schnell entludend abschaltete. Im Herbst des vorherigen Jahres gab es Unternehmen aber bekannt, dass sie das Problem gelöst haben durch ein Software-Update. Das war aber jetzt offensichtlich zu spät, denn in der Folge schaltete sich die schwedische Verbraucherschutzbehörde ein und erliess ein vorläufiges Verkaufsverbot in Schweden, das ihn sehr hart traf, diesen Hersteller, jetzt trotz des Software-Updates und obwohl es ein sehr, sehr guter Helm ist, mit so einer Kinderkrankheit, gibt es das jetzt tatsächlich, hat das jetzt so ein bisschen in die Insolvenz getrieben. Software. Weil der Test war noch mal ein Vorgängermodell, der durchgeführt werden. Verdammte Software. Ach, ist schade. Ichinte, also ein Programmierer hat da irgendwo ein Semikolon falsch gesetzt und dann sterben Leute, weil der Helm nicht aufgeht. Das tut mir echt leid, ey. Das tut mir vor allem leid für die ganzen Gehirnerschütterungen, die Leute, die dann alle auf den Kopf fallen. Das ist bitter. Das tut mir richtig, richtig leid. Ja, dann haben die sogar mit der einseitigen Verfügung den Ver Verkaufsstopp und die Rückrufanforderungen außer Kraft gesetzt, weil alles funktioniert, wie geplant, aber zu spät, am selben Tag musste das Unternehmen noch Insolvenz anmelden. Der Schaden, der durch das Verhalten der schwedischen Verbraucherschutzbehörde entstanden ist, ist so gross, dass der Vorstand keine Grundlage für die Weiterführung des Unternehmens sieht. Krass, oder? Und deswegen gibt es das nicht mehr. Und jetzt ist meine Frage, du bist ja auch auf Updates angewiesen als jetzt Kunde dieses Helms. Ja. Oder nicht. Weiss ich nicht. Muss das immer neu angepasst werden. Wenn ein Kabel ist kaputt, dann kann es ja nicht mehr es ist ja nicht mehr maintained. Kannst du ihn wegschmeißen. Weiss ich nicht. Übertrieben. Kannst du die Tonne kloppen. Aber ja, schade nicht zu fest. Wenn ihr jetzt euren Helm aus Wut in die Tonne werft, bitte nicht zu schnell, sonst geht der komplette Mülleimer auf. Wahnsinn. Okay, ja, das war die Geschichte des Airbag-Helms, den ich sehr mag, mochte. Das war's. Rest in peace. Wie weich ist so ein Airbag? Also ist das wirklich so ein Kuschelkissen oder ist das eher so ein wirklich, weil es gab ja irgendwann mal bei uns in der Schule zumindest den Punkt, wo die Sportmatten geändert wurden, von den weichen, schönen, zarten, samtigen zu wirklich so harten Matten. Wie der Boden. Wo immer es hiess, ja, die haben weniger Verletzungsgefahr, weil wenn du in den weichen Matten auftrittst, dann kann dein Knöchel irgendwie umknicken, weil diese Weiche von der Matte, keine Ahnung, so wurde es verkauft. Aber am Ende waren es einfach Pressholzplatten. Spebeliger. Und da war ich schon stock sauer und dachte, meine Zeit ist vorbei. Ich muss runter von dieser Schule, das war's. Die gute Zeit ist vorbei, aber jetzt geht sie noch bergab. Und ja, ist das dann auch so? Also, dass der Airbag härter sein muss, damit er funktioniert? Oder ist das wirklich wie so ein herrliches, so wie so ein Hotel-Kopfkissen, so richtig schön weich und man fällt da so richtig rein? Oder ist das eher wie so ein Boxhandschuh, wie so ein wirklich harter Ball? Also sieht wunderschön weich aus. Ja, das ist der Helm, der sieht wirklich sehr weich aus, das stimmt. Ich glaube, Airbags sind eher weich, aber du hast recht, man weiß es nicht genau. Vor allem, es gibt ja auch diese Aufblas-Motion, die ist wahrscheinlich schon hart, wenn man dann während der Sturz in sich explodiert.
Ich glaube, es muss schon reich sein. Ich habe so ein Video gesehen, wo irgendwie so ein Autofahrer wütend war und so vorne aufs Auto geschlagen hat von dem anderen und dann ist der Airbag aufgegangen, wo man entscheidend da irgendwie genau diese Registrierstelle war oder so. Das ist einfach so, das ist wirklich wie so der Musikantenknochen des Autos, einfach so, wo man genau so einen Punkt treffen kann und dann ist der ja ausgeschaltet. Erstmal kriegst du ein Airbag ins Gesicht und dann kannst du ja nicht einfach sagen, ja jetzt fahre ich weiter. Ich wäre dann jemand, der hätte wochenlang diesen schlaffen Airbag dann irgendwie auf dem Lenkrad hängen und würde den nicht reparieren. Und dann einfach ewig bis zur nächsten Kontrolle so, haben sie da ein Airbag? Hä? Nee, nee, das ist mein Schwangerschaftssimulator.
Genau, da ist die Fruchtblase in die, also das hängt da jetzt noch von der das ist eine Plastikfruchtblase, die simuliert, weil ich wollte wissen, wie es ist, schwanger zu sein. Genau, ich bin meine Frau und ich habe mir nicht viel gestritten, weil es irgendwie anstrengend ist und dann hat sie gesagt, nee, du musst die Emotionen und die fühlen, was ich fühle.
Genau, weil sie meinte also, ich unterstütze sie nicht genug während der Schwangerschaft. Dann meinte ich, so schlimm ist es nicht. Und dann gab es einen großen Streit. Und dann meinte sie, naja, jetzt holen wir uns dieses Schwangerschaftssimulationskit. Und dann ist eben während der Fahrt die Fruchtblase, Schatz, kannst du bitte kurz leise sein, wenn ich mit dem Machtmeister rede? Und seitdem hängt das hier. Vor allem, es gibt ja diese Videos von Männern, denen diese Schmerzdinge herangemacht haben. Die Menstruationsschmerzen simulieren. Oder Schwangerschaft, die Wehen. Ich meine wirklich die Menstruationsschmerzen. Und dann alle Männer machen dann, das war ja Stufe eins, hier ist Stufe zehn. So, das sind diese Videos immer. Und man denkt, kann nicht sein. Ja gut, aber ich glaube, die sind genau dafür gedacht für Leute wie dich. Du fällst jetzt genau in die gleiche Falle wie diese Leute aus den Videos. Nee, ich hab Menschen des Weiblichen gesteckt. Stefan, ich will jetzt nicht die Kommentare sehen. Holt für Stefan so einen Schmerzgürtel, Stefan muss leiden. Ja. Dann die sadistischen Zuhörerinnen und Zuhörer sagen, Stefan muss jetzt auch den Foltergürtel tragen. Nee, ich glaube, das wird warm nicht weh. In der Folge, macht eine Folge, wie Stefan sich in Schmerz findet. Ja, ich sehe schon den Vorteil und ich glaube, das ist genau der Effekt und es tut viel mehr weh, als Männer denken, das ist alles klar. Aber das ist ja ein extremer Schmerz, den die da haben, also so ein extremer Schmerz, dass man nicht aufrestehen kann. Ja, das ist anscheinend die Aussage, ja. Das ist die Aussage? Ja. Ja, bald, ein und bald. Ich mag, dass du so ein Video siehst, das genau diesen Punkt demonstriert und du sagst, das kann doch nicht so sein.
Doch, also bis Stufe fünf verstehe ich das. Dann gibt es so Stufen, wo du halt so viele Schmerzen hast.
Und dann habe ich auch Personen des weiblichen Geschlechts gefragt und die haben gesagt, ja, es gibt schon Frauen, die haben dann halt wahnsinnige Magenkrämpfe. Ja, wenn. Wenn das die Leute, die extrem, wir kommen in die Hölle.
Nicht mit diesem fucking Gürtel herum.
Nee, aber so wenn Menschen...
Das ist Patreon-Content.
Stefan und Florian, die liegen auf dem Boden, sich in Schmerz windend einfach.
Ja, aber ich denke mir, klar kann man auch noch schlimme...
Aber es ist ja die Ausnahme.
Wenn wir die simulieren wollen, okay.
Aber dann sollten die Videos sagen, es gibt Frauen mit extremen Magenkrämpfen währenddessen und das fühlt sich so an. Die durchschnittliche Menstruation, das wäre doch ein viel aussagekräftigeres Video, da hast du nicht so Idioten wie mich, die dann das irgendwie in Frage stellen jetzt. sondern es gibt auch youtube-kommentare also du kannst da einfach deinen kommentar posten
ich verstehe was du meinst aber es schon interessant, weil gibt es so einen maximalen Schmerz? Weil ich habe zum Beispiel bei der Schärfe Wikipedia-Artikel-Recherche auch gelesen, es gibt einen Punkt, ab dem wird es nicht mehr schärfer. Ab dem wird mehr Schärfe, also mehr Skowil, nicht mehr als mehr Schärfe wagen. Ich glaube so 1,5 Millionen oder irgendwie sowas halt ultra hoch. Und dann dachte ich mir erst mal Respekt an die Leute, die das herausgefunden haben, die wirklich diesen brutalsten Schärfe und dann so nee, also über Todesqualen geht es eigentlich nicht mehr hinaus, da wird es dann nicht noch schlimmer, wenn man dann dreitausend Scoville oder reines von diesem Zeug da nutzt, aber da gibt es ein Maximum, ich glaube beim körperlichen Schmerz ist es auch so. Ist es nicht so mit diesen Tasern, dass, da, ich hab mal gehört, so, das ist für einen kurzen Moment der, der, der schlimmste Schmerz, den du je spüren würdest. So, aber nur für einen kurzen Moment. Da denkt man sich ja schon so, da muss ich es mal ausprobieren, einfach mal so den, also einfach damit ich weiss, wo auf der Skala ich bin. Wenn ich jetzt das nächste Mal Rückenschmerzen bekomme, kann ich dann sagen, okay, wir sind schon 90 Prozent da oder das ist überhaupt 20 Prozent des maximalen Schmerzes. Ja, spannend. Aber der Typ der ist die Scoville-Skala, also Herr Scoville, der hat das alles erforscht, aber der Erste, der gesagt hat, wir haben hier zu Gast, Herr Scoville. Hallo! Ich freue mich sehr über die Einladung.
Sie essen ganz nackt Chili? Ja. Und warum? Aus beruflichen Gründen.
Was machen Sie denn beruflich? Kann ich in Klassmärchen?
Tut mir leid, wir haben leider nichts im Studios, tut mir leid.
Wie viele Scooby war das jetzt? Fünf Millionen. Das ist schon ziemlich hoch. Goville. Weil am Anfang war das tatsächlich, die Skala war am Anfang tatsächlich subjektiv, mittlerweile wird sie aber chemisch irgendwie gemessen an wie viel von diesem Zeug da in den Chilis drin ist und dann kann man das tatsächlich objektiv benennen, aber anfangs war es subjektiv. Weil Leute mit ihren Reagenzgläschen, die ineinander gekippt haben und dann mit Brodel, Brodel, Brodel und braun, braunämliche Substanzen vor sich hin. Ich muss da immer an diese eine Szene denken, ich weiß nicht, was es war, ich glaube, es war so Schlag den Raab oder Duell um die Welt, irgendeine Sendung mit riesigem Live-Publikum und da gab es auch irgendeine Challenge mit super scharfer Chili. Sagen wir jetzt einfach mal,
Joko muss die schärfste Chili
der Welt essen, sowas, so eine Geschichte.
Und dann haben die das gemacht oder nicht
gemacht und dann hat die
Moderatorin, sagen wir mal Janine Michaelsen
Ich weiß nicht genau, wer es war,
aber irgendwie sowas in der Ecke. Und dann hat
die gemeint so,
hat jemand aus dem Publikum Interesse, diese Chili zu essen, weil anscheinend Joko sie nicht gegessen hat. Dann kam erst mal Werbung von, sagen wir mal, Audi oder so, weiss ich nicht, so zum Beispiel. Und dann meinte sie so in ihrem blauen Kleid, sagen wir jetzt mal, und sie hatte so die Haare von, die Pony so, weiss jetzt nicht mehr, aber so wie Pony und so.
Und dann hat sie so in der Schule gekommen, war rot oder blau, weiß jetzt nicht mehr genau, es war ProSieben oder Sat.1.
So, und dann hat sie gefragt, will jemand aus dem Publikum diese Chili essen? Und dann hat sich tatsächlich jemand gemeldet, der meinte so, ja, ich bin der Ronny und ich mag ja generell Schärfe und ich habe schon die schärfste Soße gegessen und so. Und der hat dann diese Chili anscheinend bekommen und hat die gegessen. Und dann alle Applaus, Applaus, Applaus, Ronny, kein Problem, wunderbar und die Sendung geht weiter. und zehn Minuten später schaut Janine Michael noch mal so ins Publikum und meinte,
ich glaube, wir müssen noch mal ganz kurz zu Ronny, weil Ronny wirklich völlig am Ende, tränend, schweiss meinte, vielleicht der Milch oder irgendwie sowas und Janine Michael so, ah okay und dann war anscheinend auch Milch vorbereitet dafür und dann hat man das dem gegeben, aber ich muss immer wieder an diesen Moment denken, der so unfassbar unangenehm ist mit Ich bin der krasseste und dieser arme Mensch saß zehn Minuten in dieser Live-Sendung wahrscheinlich die schlimmsten Schmerzen, weil du kannst ja einfach aufstehen und gehen und was trinken und so, sondern so ein schwenkiges Publikum und dieser eine Platz ist leer, das ist ein anderer. Wo ist jetzt ein anderer auf diesem Platz?
Wo ist Ronny?
Und diese zehn Minuten und du willst jetzt nicht in der Live-Sendung sagen, Entschuldigung, Frau Michaelsen.
Können wir kurz anhalten, ich mache Milch.
Es gibt dafür keine Möglichkeit, du musst da sitzen und einfach ertragen.
Und der einfach nur darauf angewiesen war, dass irgendjemand von Aufnahmeleitung, whatever, seinen Schmerz irgendwie registriert, um ihm zu helfen. Ich glaube, das ist die schlimmste Situation der Welt. Ich wäre da einfach eingegangen. Aber dann Pops an Jan-Michaelsen oder alle anderen Moderatorinnen, die es gewesen sein können, das erkannt zu haben. Wir müssen glaube ich nochmal zu Ronny darüber gehen, fand ich super. Total, wirklich ein großer Moment. Oder wie er hieß, aber es ist auch egal für die Story. Aber ich muss immer noch denken, weil das ist einfach, es ist auch mein Unterschätzte stark, man denkt, ja, ich bin Schärfe gewohnt, kein Problem, aber es ist einfach wie Gift, einfach so, das ist einfach körperliches Ding, da bist du einfach, hast du keine Macht drüber. Mega Idee, auch Hot Ones, dieses Interviewformat, wo es immer schärfer wird und die immer Chicken Wings essen, die immer schärfer werden. Mit prominenten Leuten, die interviewt werden und dadurch so ein bisschen authentisch oder weinend. Authentischer, genau. Also ich weiß nicht, ob es das authentischere Interview ist, aber die Schmerzen sind es und vielleicht kommen die Antworten dadurch auch ein bisschen authentischer. Ich mag die Interviews sehr gerne, aber es ist auch cool. Ich habe lange gedacht, es heisst Hot Ones. Ah, Hot Onones. Jotones. Jotones. Weil es hat diesen spanischen, mexikanischen Flair mit diesen Flammen im Logo. Ah ja. Deswegen hätte ich immer Jotones gedacht. Aber das seid ihr einfach Hot Ones. Von daher, glaubt nicht, was ihr seht. Und wenn Stefan euch Sendungen auf YouTube empfiehlt, fragt nochmal ganz genau nach, wie die geschrieben werden. Ey, du musst dir unbedingt Jotones anschauen. Chortones? Okay. Und Musi-Klig. Kannst du es mir buchstabieren? Musi-Klig. Die App. Wo man mit Sugar Babes. S-U-G-A. Sugar Babes. Sugar Babes. Sugar Babes. Sugar Babes. Sugar Babes. Ja, ich möchte euch nichts mehr empfehlen, weil ich wahrscheinlich verspreche.
Nee, das Problem ist nicht, dass du nicht widersprichst, sondern dass du mit zu viel Selbstbewusstsein unhinterfragt deine persönliche Aussprache als normal darstellst.
Alle anderen, die sagen, es gibt bessere Interviewformate als Chotones, haben keine Ahnung in Ohren. Und deswegen sind sie Loser. Chotones ist das beste Interviewformat. Und alle, die zuhören. Hey, was war das für eine? Geht es Stefan gut eigentlich? Kann ich mal nachfragen, geht es dir gut? Also ausser jetzt die absolut niederschmetternden Rückenschmerzen. Nein, furchtbare Schmerzen. Ja, immer noch jetzt gerade im Moment. Ja, gerade im Moment. Unsere Stühle sind auch nicht gut, ne, wir hätten nicht für das billigste Modell entscheiden sollen. Wir haben kack Stühle. Okay, also ja, okay, tut mir leid, Stefan. Ich hätte den Link geschickt und gesagt, sind die cool, du hast nicht darauf reagiert. Ja, weil Stühle sind dir wichtiger, mir sind Stühle nicht so wichtig.
Mir sind Stühle nicht so wichtig?
Mir sind Stühle überhaupt nicht wichtig. Ich liege ja meistens seitlich im Bett.
Seitlich liegst du im Bett, warum war das jetzt so seitlich wichtig?
Und das hat mir tatsächlich auch ein bisschen geholfen, weil das Schlimmste beim Rückenschmerzen ist ja die Nacht.
Du musst ja irgendwie durch die Nacht kommen, weil du kannst nicht schlafen, weil dein Körper sagt,
hallo, hallo, wir dürfen nicht schlafen und du sagst, warum nicht und der Körper, hallo, hallo, heute wird nicht geschlafen, warum denn nicht, es ist doch gut für uns, wenn wir schlafen und dann lag ich so seitlich und das hat dann einigermaßen geholfen, so ein bisschen, da bin ich zumindest durch die Nacht gekommen und hab dann mir lustige Dokus angeschaut. Das klingt nicht nach schlafen, ehrlich gesagt. Es war nicht wirklich schlafen, aber es klingt nach Dokus gucken. Ja, manchmal wird angeguckt von David Beckham. Okay, die soll cool sein. Angeguckt und von Robbie Williams. Und für mich sind dann irgendwie, dadurch, dass ich die direkt hintereinander geguckt habe, irgendwie diese beiden Menschen ineinander verschwollen. Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich es immer schon verwechselt habe.
Aber irgendwie sind die auch ähnlich.
Ich finde, beide so Engländer, so ja,
klassische, ja, so Lad,
so Malad und so.
Rockstar-Engländer.
Und deswegen irgendwie sind die
verschw... Ich weiß auch nicht viel gemeinsam,
aber ich verstehe, das ist mein, das ist
denkst du sie. Der war ja in,
der eine war ja Musiker in Take This und der andere Musiker in Take That. Genau. Also das ist ein kleiner Unterschied zuerst. Du bist aber eher Team. Ich bin eher Take This. Ich auch. Team Take This, das war ja damals der grosse Boy-Bernstreit, genauso mit den Sugar Babes, mit S-U-G-A und die Sugar Babes, mit S-U-G-I-R Babes. Da war es ja auch ein grosser Kampf und deswegen.
Genau und nicht zu verwechseln, das fand ich noch am besten, der Krieg zwischen Destiny's Child und Fate Child. Ja. Das fand ich so gut. Ja, oder noch mal unvergessen die Schlacht zwischen Pussycat-Dolls und den Cat-Pussy-Dolls, die natürlich sich da wirklich, also es kam natürlich auch zu menschenverachtenden Szenen und Kriegsverbrechen, die wir jetzt nicht unter den Bombenteppich kehren möchten, überhaupt nicht, sondern den möchten wir wirklich ernst und mit voller Inbrunst in die Augen sehen und ihn als das verurteilen, was es war, Mord. Ja, ich habe bei dem Satz vergessen, wo wir herkamen ursprünglich, aber du wirst den schon richtig zu Ende geführt sollen. Ich habe ihn eingepackt. Ich habe den Satz rückwärts, den rückwärts eingeparkt, im Halteverbot, aber gut eingeparkt, aber statt im Halteverbot. Ja, ist völlig okay. Ja, ich wünsche euch eine schöne Woche, kommt gut durch die Woche. Ihr merkt das, wir gehen locker, starten wir ins Jahr. Ich weiß nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist mittlerweile angemerkt worden, da gibt es jetzt keine großen... Jetzt ist es ja erst Januar, weißt du, was ich meine? Im Sinne von, wie arbeiten Menschen? Also es ist ja erst Januar, erst mal locker reinkommen. Dann ist Februar immer noch eisig kalt. Im März kann man mal loslegen, dann ist es auch schon Mitte des Jahres, sind auch schon Osterferien. Stellt euch vor wie neue Schuhe, die erst so eingelaufen werden müssen, wo man jetzt auch nicht irgendwie auf den Berg geht, sondern wo man erstmal locker damit durch die Fussgängerzone flaniert, damit einfach die Schuhe so ein bisschen ran gewöhnt werden. Völlig richtig. Aber gegen Ende des Jahres ziehen wir das Tempo ein bisschen an. Wie immer das treffendste Beispiel, was man nicht stretchen muss, damit es irgendwie in die Form passt, sondern das war wieder ein Spot-on-Beispiel. Wir sind wie sich einlaufende Schuhe. Ich wünsche euch eine ganz schöne Woche, haut rein, macht's gut. Macht's gut. Stürzt nicht, bitte, achtet darauf, dass ihr immer Behälmung tragt. Lass mal diese Woche das Kreuzheben sein. Macht eine andere Übung, macht eine Massage oder macht die Kuh Katze. Oh ja, Katze Kuh.
Macht's gut, hat Reinhard eine schöne Woche, wir heben abstehend, macht's gut, tschüss!